Thank you.
Thank you Hadley.
The title of this
talk is RStudio 2022.
But the actual
subject of the talk
is to consider the
question of what would it
take for us to give this
same talk in 2122?
That's what we're going to
try to consider here today.
And to do that, we want to
start by reflecting back
a little bit on
where we've been.
And I want to point out now that
if you go to a tech conference
and the founders are
on stage and they
say we have some exciting
news, and the first slide says,
our journey so far there's a
95% chance the company's
getting acquired.
So that is not at all
what's happening today
and that will never happen.
So, yeah, that might have
occurred to some of you.
So anyway, we are feeling
incredibly blessed
to be part of this community.
And you know, the company
started 13 years ago,
but many of us have actually
been working on and with R
far longer than that.
And we've built a set
of tools and software
that helps people ask and answer
the hardest questions with code
in a reproducible fashion,
and all the while
creating an incredible
community, which
I think if you're
here today, you
feel if you've been
at past confs, meetups, all
the interactions
we have online, I
think the community
we've built together is,
is really remarkable.
And also I wanted to
reflect back on what
the most difficult
problem that we've
solved so far as a company.
And one very obvious
answer to this question,
and it is a
difficult problem, is
that we've made R usable and
productive and approachable
for many, many,
many, many people,
many more people than
probably any of us
thought would be possible.
And that is a difficult problem.
It's a very important problem.
It kind of enables all
the things I talked about
on the first slide.
But when me and Hadley and Joe
and others all got together,
all got together
about 10 years ago
and said, hey, let's work on
this together for a long time,
I actually was pretty
confident that we would
be able to solve this problem.
But there's another problem
that I think we have solved,
which I wasn't 100% confident
we'd be able to solve.
I hoped, but I was
100% confident,
which is to create a sustainable
model for funding open source
scientific software.
Scientific software is
traditionally created
by large proprietary
software vendors,
kind of necessarily so in a
way, because it's actually
there's a lot of software to be
written about, a lot of people
depend on it.
But we really felt
strongly that we'd
like to find a way to make open
source software for science
sustainable.
And reflecting a little bit
on why this problem matters.
I think actually everyone here
has a pretty good intuition
about why this problem matters.
And that was a subject of a talk
I gave a couple of years ago.
OK OK.
Use this instead.
OK, great.
As a subject of a talk I
gave a couple of years ago,
reflecting a little bit on
the most important dimensions
of that, the scientific process
and the scientific method
depends on replication
and reproducibility.
And fundamentally, if I can't
run your software either
over space, you
know, a colleague
in another company or another
country or another university,
or over time, if I
can't run your software,
I can't reproduce your work
and I can't build on your work.
So having the fundamental
software be free and open
source kind of
ensures or at least
creates the conditions for
widespread reproducibility
and replicability
and also resiliency.
Software does die.
Companies die.
Versions of products die.
Things get out of fashion.
Open source software has
that fundamental right
to fork, which means that
software can persist even
beyond the time period over
which its main sponsors are
working on it.
And then finally, participation
you've seen with CRAN.
Tens of thousands of
packages addressing
all different domains,
methodological approaches
and having the user community
be part of building the tools
and deciding what
methods are supported
is fundamentally better than
the idea of a single vendor
or a couple of vendors
being a choke point, sort
of deciding what an analytic
methods people are going to be
able to use with the software.
So I think this problem
matters a great deal
to science, data science,
science, the future of science.
And so when we think
about the solving
this problem of sustainable
funding for open source
scientific software, there's a
few dimensions of the problem.
Some of it has to do with just
the mission of the entities
that are working on it.
Some of it actually has to do
with the way incentives are
aligned around the work.
And then and then even if
you have those things right,
getting to a certain
scale of effort
is actually another
threshold condition.
Companies like Wolfram
and MathWorks and SAS,
you know, employ
hundreds of people
to work on scientific software.
And I think something
along that those lines
is, is probably necessary
to do it really well
with open source.
So first kind of the
corporate charter
and again we talked about this
a couple of years ago at conf
and it's important to note that
when we became a public benefit
corporation, we actually
encoded our mission
into the corporate charter.
And it actually is the case
that our directors and officers
have a fiduciary duty
to pursue this mission.
And that mission,
when we wrote it,
I think about three years
ago, was actually written.
You'll notice here
pretty broadly,
we talk about free and
open source software
for data science,
scientific research
and technical communication.
And partly even at the
time we were exclusively
focused on data science.
We sense that the kind
of model we were building
might have broader application,
and we wanted the mission
statement to reflect that.
So that's the charter.
But then there's
incentive structures.
I would say that many or
most software companies
and technology
companies have kind
of the seeds of their own
demise planted in them
from the earliest days.
Startup companies often exist to
be, really exist, to be acquired.
And once they're acquired,
all kinds of things
happen to their software
and their mission.
their people. Even public
companies who are not acquired,
who are nominally
independent, are
really, there's a pretty narrow
lane they have to exist in,
which is to always grow,
always grow their revenue,
always grow their earnings, kind
of at the expense of everything
else.
And that certainly also
causes missions to drift.
And so the thing that I'm really
pleased about with RStudio
is that we actually are
an independent company.
We're committed to always
being an independent company,
and the control of the company
lies inside the company.
People who work at
RStudio fundamentally
control the company.
It's not controlled
from the outside.
So we actually can
say we're not going
to be, we're going to
continue to be independent.
We can follow through on that.
And for us, our imperative, we
certainly would like to grow,
but it's not growth at
all costs and it's never
at the expense of
our core mission.
And so our hope maybe
it's a little optimistic,
but we'd like to
be here fulfilling
that mission in 100 years.
We're certainly going to
think as if we are or try to.
And make our work and company
be organically sustainable.
And then finally, there's a
question of scale of effort.
And I'm really happy about
the fact that about 40%
of our engineers work full
time on open source software.
This is a list of some of
our open source projects
and the number of
full time engineers
that work on them as of now.
That's 43 engineers.
But there's more than that.
We actually have
dozens of people
at the company who are not
full time open source software
engineers who also write
packages and contribute
to open source projects.
So there's many
more than the 43,
but there's 43 who
are paid to do nothing
but work on open
source software.
43 is great.
I hope in five years
that's going to be 143
and I hope in 10 years.
That's going to be 200 or 300.
And I think that
represents an opportunity
to create a scale of effort
that is really remarkable
and actually presents
an opportunity.
Talking a little bit about how
we kind of got to this scale
with the basic
mechanic is, and I
think I talked about this
a couple of years ago,
to briefly recap,
recount it, there's
a virtuous cycle,
synergistic relationship
between our open source and
our commercial software.
We write open source tools that
are accessible to everyone.
They're accessible
to anyone independent
of their economic means.
And they're there.
They're really
useful as they are,
without purchasing anything.
But what happens
is that inevitably,
when lots and lots of people
adopt open source software,
some of that software is
adopted in complex environments,
larger organizations that
have security or scalability
or integration requirements.
People want to use this
software, deploy the software
and use the software on the web.
And that creates an
opportunity for us
to create commercial
products, which
then help grow the company
and allow us to invest back
in our open source tools.
Now, I want to tie
this back a little
bit to the stuff about
mission and incentives.
You'll notice
there's a line here.
There's a line between
open source and enterprise
products and a company,
and we've seen this we've seen
this historically, companies
whose principal imperative
is growth at any cost
actually have an incentive
to move that line over time.
And what I think is great
about what we've done,
because we have
the independence,
is that we actually have an
operative principle for what's
open source and what is not.
And that is really that the
core intellectual property
that you create - the reports,
applications, analyses, code - that
is all based on open
source packages,
protocols, file formats and
even the core productivity
tools like RStudio
are open source
so that anyone can use them.
And then when we get
into these scenarios
of more complex
environments, that's
when, or deployment
on the web, that's
when commercial software
comes into play.
But we will always
respect that line
and never compromise that
line for the sake of,
of goosing our growth for any
given year or period of time.
And I apologize.
actually, I don't
think the type here
is going to be super legible
for people past the 10th row.
But this is just a picture of
the company over time, kind
of how this has played out.
In 2009, it was one person
four years later, in 2013,
there were six
people just working
on open source software.
And then about five years
into the company's life,
we decided that we'd like to try
to grow this group and do more.
As you can see, we
started introducing
some commercial products
that actually worked
and we became
profitable very quickly,
and we've managed to grow
really, really substantially
since then and create a lot of,
this is just, this is only some
of the open source software
that we've created.
And as you can see
also, we've managed
to fill in additional
commercial products for all
the different scenarios
that people have
and that these things,
again, are feeding each other
and allow us to get to
this scale of roughly now
about 250 people in the company
and dozens and dozens of people
working full time on
open source software.
So where does this leave us?
We talked about that's
kind of RStudio 2022.
And we talked about where
do we go in the future?
And I think what's remarkable
to me is that we have actually
built this company that
can have open source
software for
science at its core,
and it's able to
fulfill that mission
as an independent company.
And we're able to employ lots
and lots of people working
on open source software
and the potential
to employ many, many more.
But when we wrote
that mission, we
included scientific research
and technical communication.
And as you've
probably already seen
with Quarto, which you'll
hear more about tomorrow,
we're starting to
work in that realm
of scientific communication.
It certainly overlaps
with data science,
but it goes
significantly beyond it.
So we've been asking ourselves
the question and really
when we started, we
worked on that mission
and we worked on Quarto, you
know, do we have the potential
does the company
have the potential
to impact the
practice of science
more broadly than
just the practice
of data science with R?
And I think the fact that we
wrote the mission that way,
the fact that a
lot of the things
you've seen us working on
over the last couple of years,
to me the answer to that is
pretty decisively that we can
and we should do that.
So to sum up.
We think we've got a
really good foundation
towards a sustainable model
for funding open source,
scientific software.
And we want to do that by
creating this long term,
thriving, trustworthy company
that's hopefully going to be
around 100 years from now.
And 100 years is a long time.
Like programming has only
been around for 70 years.
Data science, charitably,
has been around for 30 years.
The languages today like
R and Julia and Python.
Are they going to be popular
even in 30 years or 50
years, let alone 100 years?
So it's pretty clear that
as much as we individually
love specific programming
languages to thrive
in the long term, the
mission of the company
has to be broader than that.
And I think you can kind
of see that today already
like one language is not
enough for most data scientists
because most data
scientists have
to use SQL and something else.
And many teams use a
combination of R and Python.
And as soon as those
teams want to interop
with the rest of the
company, even more languages
come onto the table.
And we believe this is
a fundamental property
of software.
Like, there's never going to be
one language to rule them all.
And so the best tools have
to take this into account.
And I think we're already
seeing this in open source tools
like Torch and Tensorflow,
which are tools
for doing deep learning, machine
learning, where you express
your model in a human friendly
language, a language designed
to interact with humans
like R or Python.
And behind the
scenes, your model
is
converted into something
very high performance.
Well, Stan, very similar
to Torch and Tensorflow,
but more statistical
computing environment really
helps fit many Bayesian models.
You define your model in a high
level language like R or Python
or Stata or Matlab, and
then behind the scenes
that's converted to
something very performant.
Or Arrow by our friends
at Voltron Data. Arrow
is a data format designed so
that different languages can
collaborate on literally
the same data in memory.
So there's none of
this kind of expensive
copying or transforming that
the different languages can
collaborate on exactly
the same data set.
And we're very much inspired
by R. R is not a language
like driven by purity
of its philosophy. R
is a language designed
to get shit done.
And it's been this, it's
been like this from day one.
Yes, the precursor
to R was designed
by statisticians at Bell Labs.
It had all these
little Fortran programs
that each tackled a
little bit of the data
science of the statistical
analysis problem,
but they needed some tool
kit to join them together.
So R, from day one has
always been about building
bridges, combining tools
to get things done.
And even our pro products are
kind of already multilingual,
like RStudio Workbench.
Of course, it
supports RStudio IDE,
but it also supports Jupyter
notebooks, Jupyter lab and Visual
Studio code. RStudio Connect,
of course, it can deploy Shiny
apps and R Markdown documents,
but it can also deploy Jupyter
notebooks and Flask APIs
and Dash and Streamlit apps.
RStudio Package Manager
is not just about R packages,
it's also about Python packages.
But there's something
about those names.
Like, RStudio was a great
name for the company
when our one product was literally
a RStudio for writing R code.
But over the last
few years, that name
has started to feel
increasingly constraining.
So today, I'm very
excited to announce
that RStudio is becoming.
Posit. So posit is a real word.
Admittedly, it's a bit
of an obscure word,
but it means to
put forth an idea
to pretend that
something is true.
So that you can argue about it.
And this is like literally
what data scientists do.
They posit hypotheses.
So that they can test or
evaluate them with data.
So why do we like this name?
While it's a real word
and it's authentic, like,
it's literally what you all do.
It's specific.
It's not some, like,
gobbledygook series
of letters that
could mean anything,
but it also feels
kind of generic enough
to last us for a
long time to come.
And if you know anything about
my personal package naming
philosophy, you'll also
know it makes me very happy
that it's exactly
five letters long.
So as well as the
new name posit,
we have a new logo which
evokes the greater than or less
than symbols of statistics
and mathematics,
the angled brackets of
HTML that greater than sign
that you see the
console all the time.
But also this idea
that weaving together
different tools,
different languages,
different environments,
different skills,
is stronger than they are alone.
So how do we get this name?
It was a lot of work.
We partnered with
a branding agency
who did a lot of research,
talking to RStudio employees
and customers,
community members,
trying to figure out like
who we are as a company.
What's our DNA?
Then that went on to a
bunch of brainstorming.
I think they brainstormed
over 500 names that
got weeded down to about
80, which we looked at.
We shortlisted about five, kind
of sat on it for about a week,
but Posit
very, very quickly,
kind of rose to the top.
So what does this mean?
Well for our Pro products,
not much, as I
said, they already
support multiple languages.
They're not
really going to change.
But hopefully now it's
a little bit easier
to tell that multilingual story
if you're an R user embedded
in a Python heavy
team or org, hopefully
it's a little bit easier
to get your colleagues
to take a look at
Posit than it would
be to get them to take
a look at RStudio.
And over time, in
the coming months,
the names of our products
will change Posit Connect,
Posit Workbench, Posit
Package Manager and so on.
What about for open source?
Well, the IDE is
already multilingual,
not just R and Python,
but it supports C and C++
and JavaScript and HTML
and a bunch of other stuff.
Keep doing that.
But we're also going to
increase our investments
in Visual Studio code.
But R markdown, it is
evolving to Quarto.
You're going to hear a lot
about Quarto at this conference.
I highly recommend
you come back tomorrow
for Julia and Mine's
keynote, which
is going to be all about Quarto.
But basically
very, very briefly,
Quarto is like R Markdown, but
designed from the foundations
to be multi-lingual,
not just R or Python,
but any language that might
come along in the future.
But tidymodels, mlverse,
MLops.
These are already
fundamentally about connecting
different systems and
languages and paradigms that
will keep going.
Just be more of the same.
The Shiny.
Well, that is a
very good question.
And if you want to
find out the answer,
you'll have to wait for
Joe's keynote this afternoon.
What about the tidyverse?
Well, I still believe that
R is the best language
for interactive data science.
We're not going to
stop investing in it.
I will learn a little
bit about Python,
but I'm not going to stop,
stop writing R code.
But of course, we're
also going to broaden
our focus a little bit,
start thinking, start doing
a little experiment about
how we can help folks
in other language communities.
And you can expect us
to hire more people who
are multilingual.
Now, most importantly,
the question
you've all been
asking yourself, well,
what does this
mean for stickers?
Well, most excitingly, if you
look underneath your seat,
there is both,
it's really wedged under there,
so you might have to
do this after the talk,
but you'll find not only a
new Posit sticker, but also
kind of a commemorative
RStudio sticker
to support to recognize the
name that stood us in stead
for so long.
One lucky audience
member will also
find a golden ticket, which
is a free registration
to the conference next year.
We're still pausing for excitement.
Yeah so Hadley talked a
little bit about, you know,
the current projects
we're working on
and where those stand and what
you can expect to see over
the next couple few years.
But I wanted to address
very, very big picture.
Where are we going long term?
And I think you can
just look at our mission
and see that we've written
it with a much broader scope
than data science.
And we would as
we grow, we would
like to apply this solution
to funding open source
scientific software
as broadly as we can.
Now, that said, we are
very decisively oriented
toward data science
today, and that
will not change any time soon.
You can see in Quarto, which
overlaps with data science,
but also gets into
a broader focus
on scientific communication.
We'll be investing
in that quite a bit,
but I would say for the
next five or 10 years,
I think this is the
areas of investment
you're going to see us
work within. Now, over time,
over a longer period of
time, we'll certainly
be looking for opportunities
to do more and contribute more.
We don't know what that
looks like right now,
but we'll definitely be
on the lookout for it.
And so kind of going
back to our journey
and revising the
language a little bit
to be phrased a
little more generally
to talk about science for
me and for my colleagues
at RStudio and the
company, I hope
for all of you and
the broader R community.
I am very excited
about the opportunity
to take all the things that
we love about R and RStudio
and bring them to everyone.
That's what I'm
really excited about.
So I hope we can all hope
we can all do that together.
We don't have a website
yet for the new company,
but there's a little bit
of a placeholder website,
you'll see you'll see there.
Thanks, J.J.